as I am sure you've heard there's a
wedding I roll this weekend this weekend
a fairy tale comes true Rachel Megan
Marco will become the first American to
be a British royal highness finally this
is the most epic love story she used to
hold the suitcases on Deal or No Deal
and now she's marrying Prince Harry
whatever big deal
Kate Middleton was one of the stools on
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire so we all
got stories frankly I'm not impressed by
this across the pound globalist dog and
pony show and here to be not impressed
with me citizen journalist Josh sharp
and Erin Jackson guys you guys don't
care about right no but I mean those
outfits do look like you're wearing
maleficents tampons on your head what we
bought this swag out of protest yeah
we're gonna post videos of ourselves
burning it and shooting it with guns
late yeah like after this week yeah
because we do not care about this
wedding at all or they're not one but
two fabulous reception yeah or that
Meghan's dress is reportedly being
hand-stitched with beaded embellishments
and will cost 100,000 pounds I was
barely even aware of that yeah well it's
a non-story the real royal couple is
right here in America Jared and Ivanka
what's more of a fairy tale than the son
of a real estate developer marrying the
daughter of a real estate developer at a
golf course in New Jersey right
certainly better than that dump Windsor
Castle yeah all right I bet that place
doesn't even have a driving range
actually I think it does it's a castle
yeah yeah yeah we hate that we hate yeah
yeah but while we're back on the wedding
these tacky Brits are serving a lemon
elderflower cake incorporating the
bright flavors of spring Oh gag me with
a bunch of that elegant sounding Kay
whatever big woof in America you get
whatever cake you want unless you're gay
yeah obviously yes
religious freedom yeah no totally we get
it so why is everyone then freaking out
about nothing oh well not us I mean we
are totally not freaking out that these
six hundred lucky guests will be eating
[Applause]
what's Bowl food it's food not even
plates Jordan Bowl I have ever yes I
mean America invented eating out of a
bowl it's called KFC and the bowl is a
bucket you eat it with your fingers and
then whip the bucket out the window into
oncoming traffic
totally Jordan you know what and I'm
glad you asked about the guest list I
didn't ask about the guests Sir Elton
John will be there and 60% of the Spice
Girl I'm not that literally anybody
cares but the entire cast of suits was
invited know Patrick and Rick and
Gabriel and Sarah and Gina yes Jordan oh
I love this suits holy I gotta be
at this wedding so that I could be the
cool guy who ruins the ceremony by
standing up and objecting like those six
guys did at my wedding
hmm but no one at home should be
watching with this wedding starts at
what time 9:00 a.m. in London which
means 4 a.m. here by disgusting I'll
bring the chips Josh and Aaron the fight
continued